Lawrence H white is a professor of
economics at George Mason University and
a distinguished senior fellow at the FA
Hyack program for Advanced Study in
philosophy politics and economics at the
Mercatus Center
he received his a B from Harvard and his
MA and PhD from the University of
California Los Angeles he is a
contributing editor to the foundation
for economic education z' magazine the
freeman and he lectures at the
Foundation's annual seminar in advanced
austrian economics in 2008 he received
the distinguished scholar award of the
association for private enterprise
education his research has appeared in
the American Economic Review the Journal
of money credit and banking and other
leading economics journals dr. white is
the author of numerous books including
the theory of monetary institutions
renewing the search for a monetary
Constitution and the clash of economic
ideas ladies and gentlemen dr. Lawrence
white
[Applause]
well thank you all for being here it's
an honor to speak as part of this
program so most of my research has been
in monetary economics but I did write a
book called the clash of economic ideas
which has a chapter on the road to
serfdom so I guess that's how I
qualified for this series
Hayek's road to serfdom was such a
success that it actually spawned a comic
book version which is where the first
slide comes from and there is a downside
to having a comic version of your book
made which is some of your opponents may
only read the comic book version and get
a very simplified version of the
argument but it's actually a very subtle
argument and a sophisticated argument
and an important enough argument that it
made national reviews list of 100 best
non-fiction books of the century
in at number four between Orwell and or
well beat out Hayek's own constitution
of Liberty which was famously the book
that Margaret Thatcher slammed on the
table and explained to her ministers
this is what we believe
I guess she said it more loudly than
that but and above the Milton Friedman's
capitalism and freedom but these three
books Road to Serfdom
constitution of Liberty and capitalism
and freedom are not really economics
books they're by economists but they're
books
in public policy or political philosophy
and that's what distinguishes Road to
Serfdom within the greater scope of
Hayek's career it kind of marked Marx a
point at which he turned from doing pure
economics to thinking about broader
issues and constitution of Liberty was
one of the later results of that so road
to serfdom published in 1944
constitutional Liberty in 1960 up to
1941 Hayek was pretty much a technical
economist and he famously if you've seen
the rap video
you know it's famous debated with John
Maynard Keynes about business cycle
theory and that was an argument
conducted at a very high
level not meant for public consumption
but for professional economists and
along with Ludwig von Mises participate
as you heard this afternoon participated
in the socialist calculation debate
where again they were talking to other
economists and trying to convince them
that they had a rather impoverished view
of the market if they thought it could
be replaced by some central bureau with
a computer but both of these were
economics debates not so much about the
theory not so much about the practical
application of the public policy but in
the road to serfdom in the middle of
World War two Hayek decided it was
important to say something about the
bigger issues facing society and wrote
about the political power dynamics it's
the way I put it of central planning so
not just the pure economic theory of it
which he had previously talked about but
what happens when you actually try to
apply central planning to an economy
what happens in the political arena what
does it imply about the kind of power
the government has to concentrate and
how it will end up using that power and
so here he's not talking to justice
fellow economists but he's talking to
educated layman and policy makers and
the general public it was originally
written just for a British audience but
it was quickly published in an American
edition I'll come back to the book but
let me set the stage historically of the
the time in which Hayek was writing
because central planning ideas socialist
ideas fascist ideas socialism's of
different kinds were very popular
through the 1930s into the 1940s in the
United States we have Franklin Roosevelt
at his inaugural in 1933 and this is
about the most remarkable
there are many remarkable statements in
the middle of this inaugural but he's
describing the Great Depression and he
says plenty is at our doorstep but a
generous use of it languishes in the
very sight of the supply
so the idea was there was lots of goods
being produced but somehow the market
stumbled in delivering them and that's
how we got the Great Depression where
did he get that idea he got it from one
of his brain trusters named Rexford
Tugwell Rexford Tugwell is a name that
I'm Rand might have invented but it was
his actual name and the ideas in
Roosevelt's speech came from primarily
from Tugwell and some of his other
colleagues at Columbia University who
made up FDR's brain trust and in a
article in an economics journal a year
earlier
Tugwell had spelled out his version of
what happened in the crash the vast
expansion of production during the 1920s
had sort of overwhelmed markets swamped
mechanisms of an artificially limited
Commerce ended in a period of violent
reconstruction and then he poses the
question what should we do about this
shall we be unready again for the flood
of still cheaper goods so what he's
suggesting is the market can't handle it
oh no the market can't handle
technological improvements that make
goods cheaper government has to do it
and how is government's supposed to
manage the flood of cheap goods well
Tugwell had two sources of inspiration
for practical models of where he thought
this was being done one was a Soviet
Union in the 1920s he visited the Soviet
Union and came back and wrote glowing
reports about how scientifically things
were managed there and the other was
Mussolini's Italy so in his diary in
1934 he goes to Rome he's a member of
Roosevelt's administration
he's an undersecretary in the Department
of Agriculture he goes to Italy to talk
to Mussolini and this is an actual
picture of the Mussolini's lobby where
Tugwell was waiting and he writes in his
diary the night before he goes to meet
Mussolini that Mussolini's regime is
doing many of the things which seemed to
me
necessary and he doesn't mean wearing
brown shirts and rounding people up
he means planning the economy from the
center the cleanest neatest most
efficiently operating piece of social
machinery I've ever seen
it makes me envious it was possible for
members of the American left to say that
about Mussolini and they did say it up
until the time Mussolini invaded
Abyssinia and after that it became not
so not something you should admit that
you ever admired Mussolini but that was
one of the ideas that was inspiring
Tugwell so tuck moment when he became a
member of the Roosevelt administration
he was important in writing the
legislation the first New Deal
legislation that came out but here's the
theory that's inspiring it goods will
flood into markets and overwhelm them if
we don't plan to make sure we're not
overwhelmed with cheap goods so how do
you do that well like Mussolini did you
set up Corp industrial cartels you set
up partnerships between the government
big business and labor unions with
government the senior partner of course
you get them around a table and you
decide how many units should be produced
because you don't want too many that
would flood the market and you decide
then what shares of the of the output go
to each firm how many workers should be
employed by each firm what wages should
be paid so then you have a fight over
how high the wages are the technical
name for that was corporatism but it was
the economic side of Italian fascism and
this is an inspiration to the New Deal
and Tugwell doing a lot of the writing
of the legislation we get the National
Industrial Recovery Act which creates
the NRA the National Recovery
administration and what the NRA does is
group firms and labor unions and
government into industrial cartels and
it writes codes for different industries
so here's the sticker from the construct
industry and what does the code do it
says how many units are going to be
produced who's going to produce them
what how many workers you're going to
need what wages you're gonna pay and so
on the Agricultural Adjustment Act or
Triple A does the same thing for
agriculture so here's here's one of
their posters too much cotton problem
now for the point of view of consumers
of course this is crazy too much cotton
is not a problem that makes cheap cotton
that's great for consumers reduce crop
now to prevent trouble later and if you
just step back you can see the whole
theory is crazy you can increase profits
in one industry like agriculture by
cutting back output and getting monopoly
prices then you can get a bigger share
of the pie from the rest of the economy
but if every industry is cutting back
output there's gonna be less pie there
can't possibly be prosperity each
industry is cutting back output they're
not going to invest they're not going to
hire more workers they're gonna hire
fewer workers and fewer machines and it
cannot possibly grow the economy as the
expression has it these days
and after a couple years of the National
Recovery administration it became clear
that it was not helping the economy
recover it was the national anti
Recovery administration and when the
Supreme Court finally struck it down the
Roosevelt administration said let's try
something else and so we were very
fortunate in the u.s. to have this
division of powers where the Supreme
Court stepped in and said this is an
unconstitutional delegation of power I'm
not sure they do that anymore but at
least 1935 they did well let's go to
Europe now and see what's happening in
Europe and the story I'd like to tell is
of The Economist vil hem rep qey who was
teaching at the University of Marburg in
1933 I just saw a film yesterday about
Hannah Arendt the political philosopher
and in this film the story is told about
a philosopher named Edmund Husserl who
also taught at the same University and
in the same year
huh Cyril was kicked out of his job in
the philosophy department for being a
Jew repkin was not a Jew he was a Roman
Catholic rep he lost his job at the
University of Marburg because he was
giving speeches denouncing the economic
ideas of the Nazis saying they were
crazy and so after he even after he lost
his job he was still living in Marburg
and still giving speeches until one day
he's visited this is the picture by two
SS officers who explained to him that he
really should not be criticizing the
economic policies of the new government
right Hitler came to power in 32 but
rather he should be defending and
promoting the economic policies and repu
rights in his memoirs that I got so
angry with these guys
he describes one of them very charmingly
as a thorough bruiser type that was the
translation anyway he gets so angry with
these two SS agents that he says I
angrily denounced them I told him to get
out I pushed them out the door and lock
the door behind them and then I paused
and thought to myself yeah I really need
to leave the country now don't I
and he did he moved to Istanbul that was
the best job he could get and from
Istanbul he tried to puzzle out what had
happened to the German economy I tried
to understand the the fascist philosophy
and he used the term fascism not just to
apply to Italy but also to apply to the
policy that the Nazis were carrying out
in Germany and this is the way he
describes it he says there really isn't
any intellectual framework for this
they're just making it up as they go
along in fact they have a minimum of
intellectual freight and they're proud
of it so what do they want they're anti
capitalists and this becomes an
important point in the road to serfdom
as I'll mention in a minute but they
want to maintain the appearances of the
economy as it used to be so nothing
revolutionary so what you get is
piecemeal interventions into the economy
but with a kind of collectivist
phraseology it is the Nazi of course
it's short for National Socialists and
they really are socialists of a vague
sort and there are not Marxists but
they're national who are international
socialist but they're National
Socialists so and they have this
military aspect he says it's a military
anti capitalism that corresponds to a
liberalism of course in his day
liberalism meant free markets rights of
the people free trade so this is what he
writes from Istanbul trying to figure
out what are the ideas that these people
have a German another German economist
who managed to stay in Germany during
the war Walter akin writes a piece after
the war explaining how despite the lack
of this central planning ideology to
begin with Nazi Germany became a
thoroughly centrally planned economy he
says well they started out with make
work programs to pay for them the
government printed a lot of money prices
started to rise
but everybody remembered the German
hyperinflation so can't let prices rise
how do you stop that could stop the
printing presses no but then we can't
pay for our programs let's put on price
controls all right this is as other
people have said this is like the theory
that you can keep the water from boiling
you by breaking the thermometer so we
impose a general price freeze but then
the price system stops working to
allocate goods there are shortages of
everything that is underpriced so what
do you do you impose rationing firms
don't want to produce as much if they
can't cover their costs so you give them
orders you allocate raw materials to
different firms so this is the process
that we can describes by which
step-by-step because people are trying
to get around the early restrictions
then they're not providing enough
resources to the industries that are
designated everything ends up getting
controlled and of course when the nazis
decide to rearm they've got the
machinery in place they can just direct
that the electricity the steel the
rubber goes into the military factories
so they even began to distribute labour
supplies which is a polite way of saying
they told people where they had to work
so there's direct allocation of labour
and of course consumer goods so they
stopped the production of consumer goods
in order to dedicate more output to well
war material so a central planning
system arises in this kind of peace
wheel piecemeal sorry unplanned fashion
but they never stop and say we're
getting poorer why don't we go well once
they did actually the first economic
minister under Hitler was Helmut shocked
and shocked said to Hitler this is not
working it's making our economy shrink
he got fired
they put in place Goering who would
Institute five-year plans that's he
called them five-year plans okay let's
switch to the United Kingdom well
similar ideas in the United Kingdom but
here it's a definite in part Soviet
inspired idea of central economic
planning and it comes from a group
called the Fabian Society
now the Fabian Society had been around
since the 1890s and its most famous
spokesmen were Beatrice and Sidney Webb
and the playwright George Bernard Shaw
Shaw's course a lot more famous for the
plays he wrote but if you actually count
the number of words he wrote as a
pamphleteer for the Fabian Society at
outnumbers a number of words in his
plays he's a lot taller than the Webb's
- I should mention that so from the
1890s they're publishing lots and lots
of pamphlets the picture of the book I
have here is sort of the first big
collection of Fabian essays that was a
best-seller made a splash but that's
back around 1900 in the early 20th
century so the kind of things they're
proposing are minimum wages maximum work
hours nationalization of railroads
nationalization of the coal industry
nationalization of the healthcare
industry and a lot of these policies get
adopted eventually but the word fabian
comes from the roman general
Fabius Maximus Quintus Fabius Maximus
whose strategy was delay delay delay
well they're not trying to delay but
they're trying to they'll take whatever
they can get in the legislature they
don't think a revolution is necessary to
bring about socialism just get what you
can opportunistically and grow and grow
and grow the role of the government in
the economy Sydnee of Beatrice Webb go
to the Soviet Union I should also
mention they're very important in the
labor party of the three major British
parties at that time Sidney Webb in fact
at one point is general secretary of the
party and right
the party's Constitution the webscoe to
the Soviet Union in the 1930s and of
course they're shown around by the
Soviet government and shown all the
wonderful things that are going on they
see all the Potemkin villages and they
come back and write a book about all the
wonderful things that are going on in
the Soviet Union and they call it in the
first edition its Soviet Communism a new
civilization question mark in the second
edition 1937 they dropped the question
mark they are convinced that this is a
new civilization and john maynard keynes
who's not in the labour party even he's
in the liberal party it's the remnants
of the classical liberal thinking in
Great Britain and Keynes still believes
in free trade but not much else from the
liberal agenda and he reviews the web's
book on the BBC radio and this is what
he says the result is impressive they're
making a whole new set of institutions
work smoothly and successfully it's an
enthralling work and then he goes on to
say I wish we could adopt this
willingness to experiment in the UK
while of course retaining our
old-fashioned conservatism oh he hadn't
quite decided but so Keynes is on board
and he's supposed to represent the he
considers himself a member of the
classical liberal party there's of
course a third party which are the
Conservatives but the Conservatives have
gotten rather wet as Thatcher used to
say or as Harold Macmillan's nanny put
it after she read the book mr. Harold is
a dangerous pink so Harold Macmillan the
Conservative Party MP at this point but
later the Prime Minister so he's
considered an up-and-comer at this time
writes a book called the middle way so
he's not defending conserving the
traditional institutions he's saying
well we have to be somewhere halfway
between that and what the Communists are
proposing so let's just nationalize a
few industries and let's just disable
markets in a few places
let's create some industrial cartels the
way they did in the United States and so
on and that's the middle way so the
center of economic policy thinking is
very favorable to central planning when
the Labour Party takes power after the
war during the war of course there's de
facto pragmatic get the job done central
planning of the war industries at least
in both Great Britain and in the United
States in the United States it's run by
the war production board there's a
similar board called the Ministry of
production and then later the Ministry
of War production in Great Britain and
in both economies consumer goods output
is restricted in order to turn factories
over to war production and in order to
share what the Labour Party called it
was fair shares in order to allow
consumers equal shares of the very
restricted output of consumer goods
rationing is implanted rather than let
prices rise to clear the markets because
of high prices there would be
profiteering well you could prevent the
profits by allowing firms to compete to
provide the high-priced consumer goods
and that would bring the prices down but
we can't do that because we're directing
them to produce war materials so
rationing in both economies and when the
Labour Party sees this they say this is
great this is what we've been arguing
for all along now all we have to do is
convince the public the voters to retain
this system when we come out of the war
right so now we're getting close to the
date at which Hayek publishes the road
to serfdom and in 1942 the Labour Party
issues a pamphlet saying this very
explicitly we have to replace
competition with a planned society we
have to keep the wartime controls so
keep price controls on consumer goods
keep price controls on major industrial
products keep price controls on coal on
steel on electricity and then of course
markets don't allocate those things so
we the government will have to decide
what the priorities are and you know who
can be against planning any rational
person believes in planning so we're
going to have one big plan and as Hayek
later pointed out and Road to Serfdom
that the question is not who's in favor
of planning and who's against it the
question is who plans for whom do people
get to plan for themselves or is there
one plan that everybody has to go along
with but so this is the climate of
opinion that Hayek is facing the road to
serfdom emerges out of Hayek's attempts
to explain to his fellow academics and
journalists and other intellectuals
what's going on here what is the nature
of this planning that people are talking
about so the first sort of inkling of it
comes in a in 1933 Hayek taught at the
London School of Economics the London
School of Economics was actually founded
by the Fabian Society by Sidney and
Beatrice Webb and their donors and the
idea was to promote their ideas but they
believed in free discourse so they they
didn't control the hiring and the LSE
hired Hayek and Lionel Robbins and some
other classical liberals but the
Economics Department was run by a Fabian
named beverage William Beveridge
and beverage had given a speech talking
about how what's happened in Germany is
an attempt to defend the last vestiges
of free market capitalism the Nazis are
defenders of free market capitalism and
Hayek says known Hayek writes him a memo
to explain to him just how wrong he is
says no look it's socialism national
socialism it's a genuine socialist
movement and he says look at people have
been pushing anti market policies in
Germany for a long time going back to
the bismarck era going back to the
that was mentioned this afternoon the
German historical school of economists
who were all they were something there
at the time they were called the
Socialists of the chair
they were tenured professors who were
rooting for the policy of Bismarck which
was not a Marxian socialism but a kind
of conservative socialism where there's
a bigger safety net government
involvement in basic industries that
sort of thing and Hayek says ok they're
not Marxists
so they may let small shopkeepers keep
their small shops or the way he puts it
is it's a not a proletarian socialism
it's a middle class socialism but that
doesn't change that the fact that the
government is going to demand control
over all the commanding heights of the
economy over the banking system to
decide who gets investment funds over
the allocation of raw materials even
over the allocation of labor has
happened so this this memo to beverage
evolves into chapter 12 of the road to
serfdom
and there's another impetus that Hayek
is working from and that is he explains
this in a letter to walter Lippmann
walter Lippmann had written sort of the
first books in a important book in a
long time challenging the whole
centralization and central planning
socialization ideas that were so popular
in his book the good Society so Hayek
writes - Lippmann and says I wish I
could make my progressive friends the
term progressive goes back to the 19th
century it's not it's been rediscovered
by those who no longer want to call
themselves liberals but the term itself
goes back a long way I wish I could make
them understand that democracy is
possible only under capitalism so
Hayek's trying to defend the political
institutions that give ordinary citizens
of vote over important things and that's
important to recognize because some of
his critics accused him of having
anti-democratic
and the collective a collectivist
experiments lead inevitably to fascism
of one sort or the other so the Soviet
Union and Nazi Germany and fascist Italy
and Japan were all doing similar sorts
of things similar sorts of central
planning systems one way or another they
all have this in common
so in the book Hayek seems to spend more
time attacking the example of Germany
than he does the Soviet Union but partly
that was because in 1944 the Soviet
Union was an ally of Great Britain in
the United States in the war against
Germany but clearly he had both types in
mind both types of central planning
so from this memo he writes up a short
pamphlet called freedom in the economic
system he expands it a little bit and
sorry it was a magazine article first
they expands it into a pamphlet adds a
little bit but then sits down to write
the road to serfdom and he's thinking
big picture here right his he says his
concern is that we're abandoning the
tradition the individualist tradition
right so individuals make decisions for
themselves coordinated through markets
all the stuff that he had written about
in the socialist calculation debate
about how markets work which has created
Western civilization so this is not a
small technical track a New York Times
reviewer reads it and says this is a sad
and angry little book well that's two
thirds right it is sad because of what's
going on around him as I was just
describing and it is angry he's angry
that people don't seem to realize that
they're promoting a system that's going
to produce horrible results the opposite
of what well-meaning people intend so
they need to understand that what
they're calling for is not going to give
them the results they wish for it's
going to give them results that follow
from the logic of the system they're
creating not from wishful thinking
but it's not a little book it's a great
book
as the national review later recognized
and as readers recognized so as I said
it was first published for a British
audience but it caused some controversy
there so some of Hayek's friends went
especially at the University of Chicago
went shopping for a American publisher
and they got the University of Chicago
Press to bring it out commercial houses
were not interested all right the big
New York publishing houses were not
interested in the first year the
University of Chicago Press editions
sold 40,000 copies which is I can tell
you it's unheard of for an academic book
or a book by an academic press which is
what the University of Chicago Press is
The Book of the Month Club snapped it up
put out a condensed version sold 600,000
copies but the thing that really put
Hayek in the public eye was the Reader's
Digest some of you of my age and older
will remember the Reader's Digest my
parents got it every month and
incredibly it in 1945 The Reader's
Digest had 7 million subscribers 7
million subscribers I don't think
there's any magazine today that has a
hundred thousand subscribers but seven
million paper copies and of course they
were in every dentist office and every
doctor's office
Hayek's Road to Serfdom is condensed and
made the lead article in the April 45
issue and reprints are available a
million reprints are ordered so we're
talking big numbers here and the
University of Chicago Press over the
years keeps selling copies here's the
picture of the latest edition with a
picture of a young looking Hayek and the
latest edition is great because it has
the memo to beverage it has the earlier
pamphlets and it has a lot of sort of
scholarly footnotes that say here's how
Hayek is implicitly attacking here if he
doesn't name him
so The Reader's Digest a Edition appears
while Hayek is on a boat crossing the
Atlantic to come give some lectures in
the US about the book and the lectures
have been scheduled for you know
universities where he might get 50
people in the audience and he arrives in
New York and he discovers that he's
become a celebrity from the sensation
that The Reader's Digest has caused and
he talked about this in an interview
once saying imagine my surprise when
they told me we were going to go to an
auditorium with 3,000 people and there's
a bank of microphones in front of me and
a sea of expectant faces so he goes
across the country giving lectures to
huge crowds and he had never thought of
it as a book that would have any appeal
to Americans because it was mostly
inspired by what was happening in
Britain but it in the United States
there had been the the New Deal and the
intellectual opponents of the New Deal
had felt kind of defeated and of course
Roosevelt was reelected three more times
1944 Roosevelt had died but it was the
middle of what was his fourth term in
office so this was a rallying point for
people who wanted to restore a freer
market so here's the table of contents
of the book I won't try to describe
what's in each chapter and I've got
taken some pictures from the cartoon
version so somebody is announcing a plan
in the first one and in the second
picture the different planners are
fighting about what the plan ought to be
because you have to have priorities when
you have a plan and different
representatives of business and labor
and the government will have different
interests and so you have a fight
putting a whip in one guy's hand it was
a little bit over the top maybe but you
can see the violence inherent in the
system to quote Monty Python the
chapters I would particularly want to
highlight our
chapter on planning in the rule of law
because the rule of law was a concept
that had really become kind of moribund
I'm happy to see that it's been
rediscovered even on the left
since election day right the idea of
having limits on what the executive can
do without any authority other than his
own say-so has been rediscovered that's
great the question the chapter on who
whom is the idea I mentioned earlier
that it's not a question of plan or no
plan it's a question of a million plans
each person with his own plan or her own
plan coordinated through a price system
that gives people signals about what
other people want to buy but doesn't
tell anybody what they have to do with
their property versus a system in which
somebody plans for everybody else and
then private use of property is
definitely restricted whether or not
property titles are canceled so in the
Soviet Union private property is just
abolished except in you know your the
clothes on your back whereas in Nazi
Germany people are still nominally the
owners of their factories but they're
getting a memo from the government
saying this is how much you produce this
is how many people you hire and so on
all the important decisions are taken
out of their hands the chapter of why
the worse to get on top so I'll come
back to that one but the idea is that
despite the me the wishes of
well-meaning people when you concentrate
power like this the people who are going
to take the reins of power are not going
to be the most scrupulous people as one
reviewer put it
Hayek's argument amounts to saying that
if you set up a slave plantation the
most tender hearted person is not going
to get the job of doing the whipping
alright it's not how the system is going
to select for somebody who's
unscrupulous and ruthless is going to
rise to the top in this kind of system
where one will dominates all other wills
so that's the here that here's the
cartoon version somebody says all these
different plans that are being tried at
the same time if they haven't been
coordinated yet leads to chaos so
there's a call for having a coherent
plan but a coherent plan means having
somebody who decides what that which
plan that is and so the people fighting
turned to a great leader who will
implement the plan so this is a sort of
generic description of Mussolini Hitler
Stalin and Liberty suffers because when
you get to the point where people are
told where they have to work because if
you choose your own job how is that
going to be consistent with having the
right number of workers in each Factory
that's been made part of the plan so
this poor guys saying I'm not a
carpenter I'm a plumber right in a
market economy you can go be a plumber
even if being a carpenter pays better
then the market is kind of telling you
we've got more plumbers than we need
relative to carpenters but you can still
do it but somebody who's got the highest
cost of being a plumber you might put it
this way somebody who's got the best
alternatives is going to leave plumbing
when the wages get too low and it'll
sort itself out but in a planning system
it doesn't work that way it can get down
to the point where you're told what job
to take now they're an interesting
sidelight one of the reviewers of the
road to serfdom was Hayek's
colleague from the LSE a fabian
socialist named Evan Durban and Durban
says well but we in the Labour Party
understand that Liberty is a great thing
and we will never get to the point where
we allocate labor and because they were
a Labour Party right they couldn't
really say to workers we're gonna tell
you where to work their membership their
rank and file wouldn't go for that so he
promised in his review that we in the
Labour Party in 44 they were out of
power but they were just about to come
back in we will never tell workers where
they have to work and when they came to
power
they didn't there's an internal battle
within the Labour Party over just how
far the plans are going to go but the
moderates went out over a group of
economists who called themselves only a
little bit tongue-in-cheek the gossip
lanters the gospel Anne was the Soviet
system of planning and these people were
calling themselves in London Goss
planners as though it were you know
funny anyway so maybe Hayek's book had
some influence on Evan Durban and
thereby on labor policy or maybe it was
just that the workers who voted for them
wouldn't want to be told where to work
and then the last cartoon is showing a
picture of how propaganda becomes
important tool to motivate people when
their the price system is long longer
motivating people so in the socialist
calculation debate there are a lot of
words on this let me summarise them in
the socialist calculation debate Hayek
had argued on economic terms why central
planning isn't going to work in the
sense of delivering prosperity it's not
going to coordinate activities as well
as a market does and it's not going to
encourage the kind of discovery of
better ways to do things and that's what
drives the market process as I imagine
professor Kirchner said it's the
entrepreneur who drives the market
process discovering lower-cost ways to
produce things in a centrally planned
system there's no room for new plans
we're trying to get a given set of plans
to become coherent we can't introduce
new products that just messes everything
up we can't introduce new methods of
production that take less input we've
already allocated the input can't do
that so you don't get any technical
progress under this kind of system
anyway it's not going to deliver the
prosperity in the Road to Serfdom he's
making a different point but related
which is because the plan is not going
to work the planners have a choice which
is to give up the plan or to double
their efforts at making the plan work so
if you can't get the mix of consumer
goods right stop
doing so many consumer goods and then
people have to choose from among the few
things that are available to them and
Hayek is warning that this
centralization of power is dangerous
this is in a competitive system nobody
has the power to tell you what to buy
nobody has the power to tell you where
to work different businesses compete for
your custom as a customer they compete
for your labor services as a worker and
so if you don't like one boss you can
find another boss but in a centrally
planned system how is that going to work
and Hayek sees it as a real tragedy so
he's not questioning the motives of
people who are advocating central
planning he calls that people of
goodwill in Germany voted in the Nazi
Party because they thought they would
deliver a prosperity and so they thought
the socialist policies would work but
the tragedy was they got results for
civil liberties being crushed that they
hadn't anticipated so they got the
opposite of what they wanted and so it
was a warning to Great Britain let's not
go down that road you can't plan
everything and still have individual
liberty or the way Henry Hazlitt put it
is it's a warning to stop look and
listen to well-intentioned and sincere
planners and Social Democrats and Hayek
dedicates the book to socialists of all
parties and he was sincere about that he
wasn't mocking them some people on the
Left read that dedication and think it's
mockery but he's sincere he's trying to
convince them the policies you are
advocating are not going to deliver the
results you want
so stop reconsider
I mentioned the chapter on the rule of
law so the rule of law is simply the
concept that the political system ought
to be governed by preset legal
rules that are known in advance rather
than by the arbitrary discretion of
people in authority who can make stuff
up as they go along
so kind of like the Federal Reserve does
but I'm slipping into my other line of
thought there should be a predetermined
you know set of rules that everybody has
to live by people can predict what the
rules are they know what's legal what's
not legal so they can plan their
businesses they can plan their
investments their personal lives they
know what to do in order not to cross
the line but if you have a system of
central planning that's all out the
window because the planners have to be
able to adjust things however they like
they can't announce everything in
advance and actually stick to it because
the plan is typically incoherent it has
unintended consequences it doesn't
deliver what it promises so they're
going to make continual adjustments and
tinkering and they can't be pre
committed to any particular course of
action so central planning is
inconsistent with the rule of law in
that sense now Hayek is not a
libertarian at this stage in his career
anyway so he is providing intellectual
ammunition to the opponents of the New
Deal the opponents of central planning
but he says he himself says I'm not
calling for a return to some mythical
lazy fair he criticizes what he calls a
wooden insistence on quote/unquote
dogmatic laissez faire so he had his
critics from the free market side who
read the road to serfdom and said well
this isn't nearly good enough for me
although it's better than of course what
the planners are saying but there's
here's a list of the kind of government
policies that are pretty far from lays a
fair or definite steps away from it that
Hayek says we can accommodate these
without we can accommodate them within a
framework of the rule of law and so
there these are not going to lead you
down the road to serfdom but it's a
pretty extensive list so he's not
against a safety net a social insurance
system and I think
the important distinction here is
planning involves policies that
neutralize or I should say disable the
price system
right put quantitative controls on
things don't let people choose by facing
market prices and deciding how they want
to allocate things it disables the price
system so that doesn't do it anymore
and then goods have to be allocated by
decree but none of these policies does
that none of these disables the price
system so he's kind of describing the
market economies you now have in
Scandinavia so large safety net high
taxes but if you look at business
policies they're actually pretty
business friendly it's easier to
establish a business they score pretty
high on the economic freedom indexes
actually very free trade economies but
yeah high taxes in a big social safety
net and Hayek has a kind of pragmatic
reason for this which is if you make it
too austere nobody's gonna vote for it
Gary Johnson are you listening no I mean
I wish people would vote for it but
Hayek's view is if you tell people that
no safety net they're not going to vote
for it most men will bear the risks at
freedom entails only if the risks are
not prohibitively great so there has to
be some reassurance to people that they
won't be left destitute that's his view
now some readers of the book especially
on charitable readers of the book have
accused Hayek of believing that once you
take the first step away from lazy fare
you inevitably end up with full-blown
communism that's not what he says he
himself advocate as I just showed some
steps away from laissez-faire and he
didn't think those would snowball it is
a kind of slippery slope argument and it
Rives parts of it derived from Mises
argument about the logic of intervention
ISM and Mises example was suppose you
think that it would be nice to make milk
more available to poor children it's a
nice goal but then as a means for that
you choose let's put a price control on
milk so it'll be less expensive well
it's not actually going to make milk
more available to poor children it's
going to cause a shortage of milk less
milk is going to be produced at a mark
at a price that too low to clear the
market they're gonna be lines from milk
you might have to ration milk there's
gonna be less milk for everybody so if
you see that and say oh there wasn't as
much milk produced
well that's because milk producers can't
make a profit so what do we need to fix
that so now we need to control the cost
that the farmers have we need to put
price controls on rural electricity
price controls on what are the inputs
hey cows I you're getting in it's a
little technical for me but all the
inputs into farming we need to control
their prices oh but now we have
shortages of those so we need to control
all the inputs into the production of
those and then it's snowballs
so that's Mises argument about the logic
of intervention ISM and Hayek pretty
much picks that up
the trouble with partial planning is
that it forces us to further steps but
here it's conditional if it's not
inevitable if the remaining free forces
are not to upset our plans so at any
point the planners can say oh it's not
turning out how we expected let's go
back the way shock did but shock didn't
keep his job so having taken the steps
it's easier to go forward not admit your
mistakes but try to double the efforts
than it is to go back if you're a
politician but if you once you get to
comprehensive central planning then
everything else sort of falls by the
wayside
free choice and as I said earlier the
least scruple this kind of people rise
to the top of the system so
personal liberty is very much something
that the rulers put to the side it's not
their concern they're trying to get the
plan to work famous economist named Paul
Samuelson wrote the best-selling book in
economics entitled economics in fact I
was talking about it with my dinner
partner giant Samuelson took up Hayek's
thesis in his principles text which is
kind of nice publicity except that
Samuelson made a complete hash of it so
this diagram is from his 1964 paper that
preceded his actually putting it in the
textbook but it's the same diagram
basically so he interprets the Road to
Serfdom as Great Britain went from a
period of high political freedom and
high economic freedom those are the two
axes and is plunging towards serfdom
which is low political freedom and low
economic freedom but look where he's got
fascism according to Samuelson fascism
is a system of high economic freedom
what does he think a fascist economic
policy is he seems to think like
Beverage did that it's some kind of lays
a fair policy it's just completely wrong
fascism belongs where the serfdom box is
fascism is a kind of serfdom and then
Samuelson provides some empirical
evidence in the second diagram where he
counts say Norway 1950 as a country with
very low economic freedom because it's
got high taxes and a large social safety
net but that's not what Hayek's talking
about he's talking about economic
freedom in the way that impinges on the
choices people are able to make with
their own property rule of law price
system and so on at one point he put on
the second diagram he put Germany 1938
where he's got the fascism box on the
left-hand diagram so completely fanciful
reading of what Hayek's message was all
right so according to Samuel Center
the trend goes the other way there's a
trade-off between economic and political
freedom it's not that less of one means
less of the other so that's the kind of
abuse Hayek's thesis suffered at the
hands of unsympathetic interpreters let
me wrap up with this into interpretation
do I want to call it this response to
Hayek and this so this is from John
Maynard Keynes who I quoted earlier
saying great things about the web's book
about the Soviet Union Keynes is on a
boat in 1944 heading across the Atlantic
he's going to Bretton Woods where he's
going to help design the world's
monetary system along with the American
Treasury agent Harry Dexter white no
relation so they're gonna plan and out
of the Bretton Woods conference of
course comes the International Monetary
Fund in the World Bank so Keynes is on a
meeting of top level economic planners
to plan the world's monetary system and
he writes a letter from the boat to
Hayek saying it's a grand book I find
myself in agreement with virtually the
whole of it not only an agreement but
with the wood in deeply moved agreement
and this part of kaiza statement is
often quoted as though Hayek spoke was
so persuasive it even persuaded Keynes
yeah you got to keep reading and you got
to wait for the but but what we want is
not no planning or even less planning we
almost certainly want more but it's not
going to be the danger that you Hayek
think because we're going to staff the
planning bureaus with good people with
experts with Keynes's buddies from
Cambridge right if people carrying it
out or rightly orientated in their own
minds and hearts to your moral position
so as long as we have classical liberals
doing the planning everything will turn
out great
it's almost as though canes skip the
chapter on why the worst get on top okay
I'd better stop there and take questions
thanks very much
[Applause]
we now have time for a few questions
please raise your hand at the microphone
will be brought to you
how do you think the chapter on people
turning to quote great leaders and how
the worst get on top applies to the
modern political environment in the
United States let me skip to my last
slide whoops my last slide was Venezuela
so in the United States this is a
question about the election I would say
neither party neither major party spoke
to the concerns Hayek raised in the
sense that neither party said we need to
scale dramatically back on government's
role in deciding the allocation of
resources so Hilary was had no problem
with Obamacare Trump had a little bit of
a problem he was going to repeal it and
replace it with something better but
keep all the good parts so that seems to
me like a kind of wishful thinking that
you can have all the good parts without
all the unintended consequences of
subsidies and price controls and direct
allocations so nobody's advocating
central planning nobody advocates in the
modern era doing away with the market so
I think we've made some progress in that
respect but they still talk about
planning one industry at a time
Healthcare is a pretty big industry
without recognizing that the logic
doesn't stop there it's hard to confine
it to a single industry because people
are going to find ways around the
controls and then you need to block
those and then you've got more spillover
effects and so on but you are
specifically about a great leader I
don't know if I want to try to guess
what exactly people who voted for Trump
were voting for I think some were
perhaps inspired by the idea that he's a
guy who can get things done it wasn't
promising central planning though but
you know he did say these are problems
that only I can fix so there were a lot
of reasons people might have voted for
Trump that might have been one of them
the main one of course was he wasn't
Hillary Clinton so we'd have to consult
an exit poll and those are always
reliable immense popularity of the Road
to Serfdom among especially the public
was there any kind of coordinated
political or social response in terms of
you know elections afterwards or
anything that the public did in response
to to reading his work so in Great
Britain Winston Churchill in the 1970s
1945 elections after the war actually
quoted from the Road to Serfdom and said
the Labour Party wants planning and that
means they're gonna have to have a
Gestapo and that was regarded as a
little bit rhetorically crude a little
bit too harsh
and his opponent Clement Attlee the next
day issued a press release saying
Winston Churchill is quoting the ideas
of this Austrian professor
Friedrich August von Hayek he used his
middle name I guess to make him sound
more foreign who is right now supplying
ideas to the Conservative Party
so at Lee was elected in a fairly large
landslide actually so the the message
didn't go over there if you look at the
reviews in the sort of mainstream press
it's almost as though there was an
organized effort to attack and undermine
the book but there was organized
promotion of the book by Reader's Digest
by General Motors
made the condensed version available by
the people who did the cartoon version
by the foundation for economic education
which was the one free-market think-tank
around in those days so their efforts on
both sides but the opponents side pretty
much tended to caricature it like Paul
Samuelson did although there have been
exceptions one of the slides I get
didn't get to has the sort of
left-leaning economist I would say
Indian economist Nobel laureate Amartya
Sen on the 60th anniversary of the road
to serfdom had a very nice appreciation
of it and of course India went through
its own period of a kind of tyranny
under a democratically elected
government that declared an emergency
and shut down all the usual protections
of civil liberty but they were in the
middle of a system of five-year plans so
the government had the resources the
tools the levers to shut down their
opponents but anyway sense says what
Hayek warns us about is the psychology
that accompanies a concentration of
power because those who are wielding the
power are gun who are aiming at certain
goals giving them our top priority are
gonna regard concerns about rule of law
civil liberty those kind of niceties as
just so much sand that's gonna gum up
the works and they will tend to
disregard it so we have to be on the
watch for that
[Applause]